welcome welcome to your mom's house
Christina the gypsies wrapped up oh yeah
we got to get into this so last week we
did a fill her up right sealer shut song
contest right here's what happened we
have a tie uh two submissions have
gotten the most amount of votes but then
a wildcard late submission came in and
blue band deemed it's so good he said we
have to listen to it okay so first I'll
play you the first two the first two
that have the highest votes so far in
the contest okay
dealers to us from John love it
this one's a mom Holly shut clean jail
roll precise yo Lok's
I'm ready to do this shit man alright so
that's by Ali also great and then here's
the the late submission that I haven't
even heard yet but I've heard is good
from Rick here we go
he's a comedy you just want to fill okay
I read all of her old with them and you
might seal them tight you and you come
to see those
really like twice over
man I'll tell you what I this one's
really great it also stuck to the Latin
flavor of everything pretty good man
that's really good
might as well play around a pillar up
sealer so what do you say yeah okay
so fill her up seal her shut
presidential presidential edition the
presidential nominee edition right so we
have Donald Trump or Bernie Sanders yes
for the men right what are you thinking
Dart
yeah what are you thinking in terms of
those two that's not exactly the most
desirable filler up material as a lady
what you know about either I said that's
just why it's a good one is it's good
when they're both really really hot or
both really really not the thing is okay
right okay
yeah is that you want to separate the
personality from the sexual act that's
always the key to a successful filler up
right you don't you're not really
talking about the person but you're
letting the personality the sexual side
you're letting the personality dictate
what the sexuality is in a way right
right I mean I kind of imagine it's
obvious that Donald is a selfish
megalomaniac narcissistic in sadja
distich yeah it's gonna be horrible
yeah but Bernie's so timid and such a
beta male that it might be just really
her end and he's old you just talked
about I gotta say that guy knows how to
eat a box Bernie yeah how are you why do
you say that I could just see it I just
feel like it's it's part of the
foundation if you at his funeral they're
gonna talk about how I used to eat pussy
like nobody else okay I can feel it you
know he was part of those civil rights
marching things I mean he's a giver you
know that guy cares about the other man
or in the case of in the bed you care he
wants you to finish first
right that's what he's all about but I
don't want it to last very long like I
kind of almost want the selfish light
here so that it's just over like Trump
just b'gok sand then get get the fuck
out of here you know what I mean you
know you to get the fuck out Hey
first one tell him
good luck okay good luck in that case I
don't want this to be a drawn-out
cuz Bernie he's gonna light the candles
we're talking sensible massage lavender
smells ask you a question
and 100 candle bath what's wrong with
that
I don't want it with Bernie great lass
he's a sexy mailman well unless you got
the mailman blank he can I think
conversation would be fascinating I
think you'd have a nice I don't want
that okay I just want to get yours off I
just want to get in and get out of this
ordeal no I want to get out of the fill
er up sealer shut right I don't want to
participate in this one okay so I just
want to get in and out quick and the
Donald is going to be the easiest way
out
Wow I got to tell you real curveball
didn't expect that answer real uh what
are you big you're picking Bernie Oh
some quest of all you know he would be
like I'm not a gay man I know you're not
a gay man but we both got to come so
what do you need me to do your balls and
I'd be like Bernie just do what you
would do to your own balls you know
right I think he would be yeah I think I
think it would be unbearable with with
the unbearable but then again he's just
like a frat boy as a man choosing
between those two is I think it's much
easier maybe because I can't speak as a
woman as a man you gotta go with Bernie
he's gonna be a much more gentle much
more caring he's still going to come to
coming oh yeah he'll be nice and there's
more involved with buttfucking than
there is vaginal yeah Donal just gonna
come in drunk like a frat guy and just
prison pound you and it'll be done in 30
seconds like Wow
and I'll throw a towel at you and
they'll be like graves are you Trey and
sod gate you Chuck gonna drink some of
that milk you okay and the next for the
ladies so you and I are opposed on this
issue this Halloween a hot ticket item
are we and the next one is Hillary
mm-hmm or the fear under Nina
Carly Fiorina Carla Laurel áfourá Nina
from
it's easy karlie has that ice queen
fucking almost like dominatrix look like
we're from house of farts yeah I I like
Carly's style meanie
she's a meanie I like it it turns me on
I feel like and she was the CEO I think
of IBM so I'd be like let her out what
our acquisitions and mergers like we
tell me about like the first IPO you
were and should be like kid eat this
from behind you know she liked her but
managed more power bitch yeah she's a
total power bitch and I could see myself
being very excited by her see I think
Hillary is your classic closet lez she's
definitely a lez in college yeah and
then she was like can't be gay cuz I got
I want this political life I don't marry
I'll bill here bill seems acceptable so
I think Hillary is a varsity level less
right and if you want to go with that
experience she's your girl
ya know she's got years of eating box
experience I bet Wow
I feel like Carly would put cigarettes
out of my mouth yeah she will and then
she was like I gotta pee I'm like okay
I'll wait here she'll be like no open up
your mouth bro okay I should piss out
the ass no more yeah domineering yeah
why not I know I've got I'm excited
thinking about like it's actually gonna
happen I think Carly's been over there
you seen Carly I've seen Carla yeah yeah
but I feel like she's - yeah I don't
know I don't want a power bitch I can't
deal with it really well cuz I'm kind of
an alpha I think Hillary is more of like
the 70s college less that's what you
want yeah I like when um Oh Carly like
here's here's Carly I'm eating her butt
and then she's looking back like well
you got right you see I mean she's
attractive right right right
I like her mm-hmm I know Trump made a
horrific comment I know I feel like
douchebag I think between the two
there's no context for me i i'd i
disagree i think aesthetically I like
Hillary what's better
I'm I
like blondes you know yeah I'm partial
never really I've never been out with a
blonde before really nope um yeah this
here this is this is me AIESEC this is
her after I come look right you come in
those balls she's like you got any come
in those balls and then I do and then
she goes that's it
no she insults to come load the amount
of load you call that a loader you call
that a load yeah yeah hmm
look small mm-hmm how many balls do you
have half of one yeah not impressed says
Fiona Nina I go where should I come and
she goes right over here uh yeah yeah
that would be it
yeah I like her I choose her I can't
believe you're choosing Hillary but it
makes sense well I know but you're right
uh maybe she has a lot of less
experienced countless I I wouldn't be
something she really knows huh she knows
all the tricks and she's from that era
of like there's a protest Saharan Billie
and yeah college she's got that classic
less 60s 70s vibe less like full bush
free love less right that's what I'm
sayin yeah yeah just like whatever man
what you got I'll take it like just free
love Carly puts a nice on me she's like
coming yeah it's a different energy
altogether
she's too dominant for me it's I'm gonna
work